la france vole au secours d'alexei
navalni après le malaise de l'avocat
russe et opposants de vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron en vacances à bormes les
mimosas s'est dit extrêmement préoccupé
et attristé par la situation est prêt à
lui accorder l'asile politique
nous sommes évidemment extrêmement
préoccupé et attristé par la situation
d'alexandre navalni et nous avons appris
ce matin ce qui lui était arrivé nous
sommes évidemment prêts à apporter toute
l'assistance nécessaire
alexandre navalni assez proches sur le
plan sanitaire sur le plan de l'asile de
la protection j'espère surtout que il
pourra être sauvé et nous apporterons
tout le soutien qui sera demandée
d'autres attendent aussi d'être sauvés
et de recevoir le soutien qu'ils ont
demandé à la france
et pourtant rien n'y fait c'est le cas
par exemple des douars snowdon l'ancien
analyste de la cia de la msa a tenté à
deux reprises d'obtenir l'asile
politique dans l'hexagone en 2013 et en
2016 et à chaque fois sa demande est
restée lettre morte
edouard snowdon on le rappelle s'est
réfugié en russie depuis qu'il a dénoncé
en 2013
la surveillance massive des
communications et d'internet aux états
unis inculpée d'espionnage et de vol de
secrets d'état outre atlantique
il encourt jusqu'à 30 ans de prison la
france a reçu comme beaucoup d'autres
pays par l'intermédiaire de son
ambassade à moscou une demande d'asile
de monsieur edwards snowden compte tenu
des éléments d'analysé juridique et de
la situation de l'intéressé il n'y sera
pas donné suite
la situation la plus dramatique est sans
doute celle de julian assange le
fondateur de wikileaks lui aussi à
demander l'asile politique à la france
auprès de françois hollande
d'abord ma vie est aujourd'hui en danger
monsieur le président et mon intégrité
physique comme psychologique a menacé
seule la france se trouve aujourd'hui en
mesure de m'offrir la protection
nécessaire contre les persécutions
politiques dont je fais l'objet
et voici la réponse de l'elysée un
examen approfondi fait apparaître que
compte tenu des éléments juridiques et
de la situation actuelle de monsieur
assange
la france ne peut pas donner suite à sa
demande la situation de monsieur assange
ne présentent pas de danger immédiat
il fait en outre l'objet d'un mandat
d'arrêt européen
pas de danger immédiat pour quelqu'un
qui dit craindre pour sa vie
quoi qu'il en soit après sept années
passées dans l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres julian assange est depuis plus
d'un an incarcéré dans la prison de
haute sécurité de belmarsh destiné
notamment aux terroristes et là bas à en
croire son père julian assange meurt à
petit feu
julian ne va pas très bien
il est sous une pression constante
il lutte pour sa survie il est sous
traitement et ils souffrent d'une
dépression après 10 ans d'emprisonnement
arbitraire hentsch depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macro pouvoir l'elysée
continue de faire la sourde oreille à
mai avec la nomination d'eric
dupond-moretti au poste de ministre de
la justice
un espoir renaît pour celui qui est en
cours cent soixante quinze ans de prison
aux états unis pour espionnage et
piratage informatique pourquoi parce qu
eric dupond-moretti n'est pas n'importe
qui c'était l'un des avocats du lanceur
d' alerte et il avait lui même alerté le
chef de l'état en début d'année sur la
situation je cite est désespérée de
julian assange
les 175 ans de prison qu'on lui promet
aux etats unis c'est une peine indignes
insupportables et contraire à l'idée que
l'on peut tous se faire des droits de
l'homme on travaille sur la possibilité
de demander aux autorités françaises un
asile politique
notre constitution le permet pourquoi la
france est elle une terre d'asile pour
certains et pas pour d'autres
en matière de droits de l'homme et de
démocratie les mots ne s'accompagne pas
toujours d'actes en d'autres termes pour
l'elysée est liberté des uns s'arrête
peut-être où commencent les intérêts
américains